you want a feel-good story for today
feds are trying to track down the hacker
who tried to poison a tampa bay water
supply
by taking over control of a computer
system's mouse
so did i say feel good i lied because
it's actually lye
the hacker increased sodium hydroxide
that's lie
from 100 parts per million to 11 100
parts per million
lie is what you find in drain cleaners
sprinkle a lie on a dead horse and you
get a puddle of soap
cnn sprinkles it on the truth and calls
it prime time
i bring this up for one reason if we
know one thing about government and the
media
is that they can't do two things at once
hell they can barely do one thing at
once
so while this is happening you got
journalists chasing down problematic
phrases instead of
actual dangers meanwhile impeachment
part two is their theatrical therapy
designed to please reporters and dems
alike
because they are alike it won't result
in anything except delayed covert relief
and
old democrats mumbling at podiums we've
seen it before
as real threats motor on we knew this 20
years ago as we chased the carry
gary condit case and obsessed over bill
clinton's infidelities
al qaeda had other plans the world
doesn't stop for our pathetic news
cycles
the world takes advantage of our media
and our politicians
we were warned about the water supply
before
now maybe it's not a hack but an error
but i'm no expert
i'm in the media but i'm willing to bet
not a single democrat senator cares much
there's a circus in town
and they're in box seats loading up on
cotton candy and popcorn
and lies let's hope they don't drink the
water
so dana here's the deal i'm a little
skeptical about certain things i
i this bothers me because we know the
water supply is a target
but whenever somebody says hack it
always turns out to be a mistake that
somebody hits a button do you remember
the uh missile
scare in hawaii or
anthony weiner it's always a hacker do
you think this
i mean is it possible that that that
this actually is a hacker
i think it is possible if you remember
um the other story that didn't get a lot
of attention um
early last month was that of the solar
winds uh hack into
not only big corporations in america but
all across our government including
at the commerce department treasury
department and they were in there for
months they still might be in there
and actually there's not been enough
reporting on that or
basically uh acknowledgment of the
failure
of our government to protect all of us
from that
so there's that piece of it but the
other thing greg when i first heard this
story
the other night you were the first
person i thought of not because
i thought you were a hacker but because
ten years ago when we started the five
you kept talking about the hardening of
soft targets
and how technology and terrorism
wherever it was coming from apparently
they don't even know if this came from
inside the united states or outside or
even if it was a hack to your point
but you're the first person i thought of
because i said i thought greg has been
trying to warn everybody about this very
thing
yeah when i think of soft targets i
think of gut felt
all right jesse at least this hacker is
mostly peaceful right
that's right i didn't remember much from
chemistry greg but uh
i did remember that water is the source
of life and it's the building block
of civilization and if you go after the
water source
that's like pulling out the wrong jenga
piece and the tower
kaboom it all comes crashing down if
this is successful
you're looking at a mass casualty terror
attack
so what we have to do is look at this
like you said as a red flag
and promote whoever our cyber warfare
guys are
make them their own military branch like
the space force give them their own
uniforms
i guarantee you this is the wave of the
future and i'm not scared of missiles
anymore i'm afraid
of hackers and i'm not afraid of much
i don't want any lie getting on you
waters uh
uh one what it's it seems to me that we
are moving
we have moved away from the traditional
view of war
and it's now i mean if you marry a drone
with uh uh you know a packet of lie
how easy is that to just fly a drone
over over a reservoir
you don't need to hack yeah yeah yeah i
just
i just want to underline how extensive
this thing is now you know
dana talked about solar winds there have
been hacks of
hospitals there have been hacks
ransomware now you know people being
extorted and all that
so right now it looks to me like cyber
crime may be the most
extensive crime impacting america that
because it's just
everywhere and you know people talk
about the hackers but a hacker is an
actual person and maybe they're working
for somebody
but we've gotta arrest them we gotta
prosecute we gotta go after these people
because when they're
going after a water supply that means
that they're trying to kill us
yep they've got our well anyway
uh judge i was going to go say a joke
that
jesse told me this morning but i decided
not to use it
because i'm thinking differently now uh
judge um this is why i'm going to start
drinking canned beer instead of water
well that makes perfect sense because
you know old crimes are being committed
in new ways and i i realized this when
when i was prosecuting crime you know
cyber crime
is probably the number one crime that
affects americans more than any other
crime
and the hardening of the grid uh and the
hardening of anything that
protects our water supply is essential
and shame on us if we don't take
advantage of the fact that there have
been many warnings and there's a lot to
lose in this world where america is uh
you know not the favorite of some
outrageous evil countries
including people here in america